welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Marvel's secret invasion is
quickly approaching its conclusion with
the latest trailer footage revealing a
new form of super scroll or is it a
super skrolk what we are probably seeing
here is a DNA of co-obsidian a member of
thanos's black order confirmed to be
included in the Scrolls harvested tissue
of enhanced beans I'm going to break
down what this footage tells us and all
the remaining footage from trailers yet
to be seen in the series to try to guess
where this season is headed and who else
will be revealed as they scroll how will
this end okay the latest secret division
promo is titled prepare and there are
quite a few new shots in it from the
upcoming episodes let's take a look so
you are responsible for all this
oh you think I came back
still have any fight left in you
power I have
was planted between my ears by a single
mother
that ain't enough I don't know what hope
we have
your Most Wanted and hated man on the
planet
consider this a preview Nick
I'm gonna make sure you get the whole
show
you're out of moves Fury this is a
ticking time box
got to figure out which side you're on
okay so from this footage we know there
is a scene where Fury visits a cemetery
with Sonia Paul's work goes into a
mausoleum where he retrieves some
Weaponry from a tomb there's also a
scene where he confronts scroll Roadie
or scrotie AKA rava with a number of
other government agents holding Fury at
gunpoint now one question that we all
have is is rava loyal to graphic
absolutely or is she working her own
game if Bravo were smart she would use
her proximity to power to stay in hiding
after all this goes down that's assuming
graphic fails and then she could
continue to corrupt the White House in
Captain America Brave New World as they
serve a new commander-in-chief president
Thaddeus Ross we know Gaia will visit
the fury home and team up with Fury's
white Priscilla AKA Vara in a green
garden basement as they go back to back
fending off incoming assailants this
explains why the first trailer shot
showed Gaia passing the same masks in
the Fury's home the fury shot at in
episode 4. we also know from the second
trailer that the closing shot of episode
4 Taylor's corpse after the attempted
assassination of U.S president ritzen
will be shortly after followed by Gaia
finding in her father's body and crying
over it but from this new trailer the
two most provocative new shots are one a
missile silo opening up and two Fury
grappling with who I assume is graphic
and a new super scroll form fully hulked
out this is likely caused by the DNA of
Carl obsidian a witch we know from patch
trailers will be stolen from dodc
Storage since this new trailer opens
with Graphics voice saying Nick Fury my
war is already set in motion this is the
extinction of the human race I think
gravic's plan will be to launch a
nuclear ICBM at a strategic Target and
force the planet into Global nuclear
Holocaust which I guess would only
somewhat affect the skull since
radiation doesn't hurt their bodies
since their Shifty molecules can dodge
those subatomic particles like their
dodgeballs still we gotta say the
squirrels have apparently been spending
their time growing their own plant life
cultivating squirrel wine and stuff so I
don't know why they'd be so okay
wrecking Earth's ecosystem I don't know
maybe gravis gun nuke tiamat's corpse so
no one can touch adamantium inside
except him kind of a reach Theory there
so look I need food and food costs money
but last night I got Curry for my
favorite Thai place for free by using a
Visa gift card I got from answering
surveys on ipsos I say on ipsos I say
you can earn extra cash through gift
cards and rewards just by taking part in
research and answering some simple
questions there's a ton of different
gift cards to choose from but my
favorite is the Visa because I can truly
use that anywhere the surveys are quick
and easy and tailored to my interests so
it never gets boring it's become part of
my coffee routine to do a survey while I
wait for my Barista to make my drink I
mean I traded in my bad habit of Doom
scrolling for ipsos I say and how I get
delicious Curry for free what a deal I
upgraded my downtime and you can too
just click the link in the description
to start earning rewards with ipsos I
say today I assume this muscular scroll
is graphic because we already know
graphic has two of the four sources of
enhanced DNA in his Super Squirrel body
we've seen extremists we've seen Groot
so presumably he also has called
obsidian and frost Beast DNA as well but
one question why Frost piece what would
you need that for I was thinking maybe
to be more cold weather resistant for a
new nuclear winter that would follow on
this planet this fight with beefy gravic
is taking place in that super scroll
chamber in the nuclear power plant in
new skrillos which fits with the various
trailer shots we've seen a fury
approaching this same gate and engaging
graphic on this device but why would
Fury be okay with entering the space if
it's supposedly highly radioactive then
the squirrels pick this location so that
humans wouldn't come anywhere near it
this would suggest one of two options
one Fury might just have a death wish
this time is limited and he doesn't care
about exposure to radiation it's just
gonna pop in an iodine pill and hope for
the best or two the very implausible
theory that I've been Hawking on
breakdowns might actually be true there
could be two Furies one human and one
scroll a scroll immune to radiation I'm
really basing this on the fact that some
scenes Fury is randomly wearing
augmented reality glasses and other
scenes he's not this could be scroll
Fury here maybe Soarin maybe a different
scroll fighting grabbing I mean I just
don't know why else an old-timer like
Fury would so confidently take on a
super Scarlet graphic man on man
especially that look of that Sam
Jackson had on his face at the end of
episode four so who knows this Fury
might be a Scurry now another
interesting shot from the trailer
footage is a vast basement filled with
dozens and dozens of figures on glowing
gurneys we know Gaia will stumble upon
these as will Sonia fallsworth and her
team at first I thought these could be
human and horizontal fracking pods when
you look at these figures heads and feet
they really do kind of look like Scrolls
I don't think Gaia would be that shocked
to find other humans who had been
impersonated even a lot of them but to
learn that graphic found a way to
empower all of the Scrolls in his
commune into Super skrulls now that's
dangerous and pretty scary I think that
could be why that one random female
scroll in episode 2 showed graphic so
much gratitude when he returned from the
scroll Council like in order to fortify
all of these Scrolls for the harsh
conditions of a post-nuclear earth they
might all need to have some
minibullyrian prospace North Face
pullovers now James Rhodes has been the
latest Marvel hero confirmed to be the
scroll imposter of rava Kevin feige even
converted to marvel.com that Roadie has
been a scroll and passed MCU titles that
we've seen saying we like the idea fans
going back and watching some of the
other appearances of Brody and realizing
that that wasn't him I would be pretty
shocked if Brody standing on the dock at
Tony Stark's funeral and Avengers end
game was a scroll but I do think this
scene in the back of the Winter Soldier
was actually scrotie world's a crazy
place right now well nobody's stable
allies are now enemies alliances are all
torn apart the world's broken now of
course everyone
scroll for a certain amount of time as
well I think we'll get some info on him
by the end of this season Beyond those
two my squirrels vicious list includes
Val Jimmy woo since he wrote Scrolls on
a dry erase board in one division
remember that how would he know Scrolls
was he also in that briefing that
scrotie said that he saw a briefing that
probably never actually happened and
also since we see dodc in the trailer
shot and the dodc is involved I think
Ariana moyad's character agent Cleary is
high up on the list and then of course I
always have to share my reach options of
MCU characters I think will be Scrolls
happy Hogan Wong and Hank pimp but those
three might just be names on a list or
faces on a screen somewhere we're
getting close to the end so I want to
know from you what cameos are you
expecting now with sag-aftra going on
strike along with the wga just so
everyone knows new rockstars is an
independent entertainment journalism
outlet and based on sag after his
guidance we are allowed to continue
covering movies and TV shows during this
strike that said we stand both with
sagatra in the wga that these unions can
get the deals they deserve and we hope
the amptp will come back to the table
and good thing follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rocks stars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching Everybody bye
foreign